[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sofies welt
heute gibt es eine richtig schnelle
kühlschrank torte also vor dem backofen
gar nicht anmachen ihr braucht nur ein
bisschen platz im kühlschrank und die
torte ist auch wirklich im handumdrehen
fertig ich habe einen notweg kuchen
gebacken ist es ein cheesecake
eigentlich nicht ich habe frischkäse
drin aber ich hab auch joghurt drin und
also ein richtig schöne lockere torte
unten mit keks boden in der mitte mit
einer joghurt frischkäse masse und
obendrauf richtig schön mit fruchtigen
wären und ich starte jetzt auch zuerst
einmal mit der bären schicht und habe
dafür drei fürchte ausgesucht nämlich in
bern
brombeeren und blau werden ich sage euch
mal eben die zutaten für das topping
verwende ich 250 umhin bei 125 kw 125 50
gramm zucker und einen esslöffel wasser
zuerst gebe ich jetzt hier alle früchte
einfach in den topf und ihr könnt
entweder frisch früchte verwenden wenn
gerade saison ist oder einfach gefrorene
kbc die gefrorenen und diese frucht
mischung die es auch echt super
ich könnte man natürlich auch einfach
die täter wären forschung nehmen dann
müsst ihr nichts mehr zusammen mischen
seit einfach alles hier ein mit etwas
zucker und da könnt ihr je nach
geschmack auch etwas mehr zucker nehmen
oder weniger wasser und jetzt einfach
bei mittlerer hitze einkochen lassen und
anschließend werde ich sie dann noch
durch ein sieb streichen
sobald die bären dann aufgekocht sind
sind sie auch schön weil das sieht man
auch hier ganz gut und ich möchte die
kerne entfernen und daher streiche ich
sie jetzt durch ein hase und da nehme
ich jetzt am liebsten das fleißige
lieschen das ist die kleine schwester
der flotten lotte
da muss man nämlich nicht selber durch
streichen sondern ganz einfach durch die
drehbewegung machen schon ein bisschen
einfach den topf brauche ich aber gleich
den ihr seht auch dass die masse
ziemlich flüssig ist und ich möchte
gleich noch die komplette flüssigkeit
verdampfen lassen
sie habe durch streichen
[Musik]
dann schön alles abstreifen und wieder
zurück in den topf und dann lasse ich
die masse jetzt ein kochen bis fast
komplett die flüssigkeit wertung zurück
in der zwischenzeit kann ich auch schon
mal den no big boden machen einem objekt
orte braucht natürlich auch eine noweck
boden und den stelle ich jetzt heraus
löffel ist mit butter und da mache ich
noch ein bisschen tonkabohne mit rein
die löffel bist peter kleiner ich jetzt
einfach in den mixer und die butter die
wird jetzt einfach direkt geschmolzen
wir sind jetzt die keksdose und da kommt
jetzt noch ein bisschen tom carbon rein
ich mach das mal weil es so scharf ist
die raiba ist nur eine prise diesmal
berichtet lecker was ist das eine
tonkabohne und da kommt jetzt vorsichtig
die flüssige butter rein
die ist ganz heiß ganz vorsichtig du
darfst früheren okay
[Musik]
sondern einfach die flüssige butter mit
dem keks brüssel und der tonkabohne
verrühren
[Musik]
das wird auch lila das sind nämlich
blaubeeren drin du magst blaubeeren die
erlebt blaubeeren schon als baby und
jetzt sieht es aus wie je feuchter sand
am strand
wenn wir eine burg bauen dann sieht das
amt auch so aus
[Applaus]
jetzt aber hier einen bug ring auf 26 cm
eingestellt und da ist im torten retter
dritter und backpapier wird die helfen
so könnte die l eine halbe stunde
beschäftigen oder wir schützen uns
einfach so rein dass man mit jetzt schön
glatt machen mit den händen
jetzt nimmst du einfach eine burger
presse und drückst es so runter
[Musik]
aber jetzt stellen wir das schon mal in
den gefrierschrank jetzt kommt das
flotten boden in den gefrierschrank und
wir können schon mal die creme
herstellen es geht wirklich alles super
schnell du machst dich bremen alles klar
[Musik]
und das fruchtpüree ist mittlerweile
soweit eingedeckt das ist wirklich ganz
ganz dick vom löffel hier herunter
fließt also es fließt schon fast gar
nicht mehr und so nehme ich sofort
herunter und lass es dann komplett ab
gehören für die creme verwende ich
treibe terium sahne 300 gramm joghurt
dann nehme ich gerne den zehnprozentigen
150 g frischkäse den im doppel kam stufe
120 computer zucker 150 gramm ist eine
limette dies unbehandelt davon nämlich
den saft und den abrieb etwas vanille
extrakt und stelle mittels mit der oma
drücken die hat er jetzt doch keine lust
mehr beziehungsweise ober hat sie
überreden können dass sie doch in den
garten gehen
ich mache jetzt alleine weiter aber
zuerst einmal gibt es einen kleinen
exkurs in richtung geliermittel und zwar
werde ich immer wieder gefragt warum
benutzt du aber was ist der unterschied
zwischen ankara und athen kann ich auch
schon athene dafür verwenden
und da gibt's einfach unterschiede
relative ist ja ein tierisches produkt
und viele möchten ja darauf verzichten
gelatine ist im prinzip nur wichtig es
gibt einmal die platine die wird vorher
in wasser eingeweicht und wird dann
erwärmt und dann gibt's die gemahlin
gelatine die wird auch mit wasser zum
quellen gegeben und wird dann erwärmt
gelatine darf nicht kochen das heißt
gequollen gelatine oder auch die
ausgedrückte gelatine blätter die dürfen
nur kurz erwärmt werden und nicht kochen
ansonsten verlieren sie ihre binde
eigenschaft ich verwende ja ganz oft
immer ager oder athene und da ist der
unterschied im prinzip nur aka aka ist
die bio variante athene ist die nicht
bio variante
deswegen habe ich immer ganz oft gaga
verwendet und ihr müsst einfach immer
auf der produkt rückseite schauen für
wieviel milliliter reicht ein beutel
denn bei agatha sind zum beispiel zehn
gramm in einem beutel und bei ak 15
und ich glaube da ganz einfach oft
verwirrung würde ich jetzt mit agatha
arbeiten dann würde ich jetzt erst
einmal das aka aka aufkochen lassen weiß
auch zwei minuten sprudelnd kochen muss
hier muss es ja nur einmal kurz
aufgehoben daher stelle ich das kurz zur
seite und fangen jetzt erst mal an und
später ist die sahne steif schlagen
[Musik]
die sahne sind steigt die stelle ich
ganz kurz in den kühlschrank und jetzt
kann ich hier in dieser schlüssel
einfach schon mal den joghurt verrühren
mit dem frischkäse der joghurt macht das
ganze natürlich richtig schön leicht das
frisch käse dazu puderzucker ein
bisschen abheben dachte ich ich hätte
vergessen aber dann richtig habe es
jedoch erwähnt dann etwas saft limette
vanille extrakt das passt einfach die
zutaten jetzt kurz verrühren
am besten nicht so hoch da nehme ich
jetzt das vegetarische lee mittel
was übrigens auch vegan ist jetzt auch
ärger basis ist und dann redet er setzt
mit einer kalten flüssigkeit also
entweder mit wasser saft oder zum
beispiel milch an
hier im topf und diesmal wirklich nur
kurz aufkochen lassen also keine zwei
mir nur um stellen sonst bei agatha bin
ich immer ziemlich genau aber ich merke
jetzt schon obwohl es noch nicht kocht
wird schon fest das klappt bestimmt
jetzt kocht schon und es auch schon
deutlich eingedeckt und jetzt
anscheinend auch kein
temperaturausgleich nötig also direkt in
die ansteckende masse einrühren
ich habe es mal alles jetzt geholt was
ihr noch brauche denn ich glaube es wird
relativ schnell fest also ohne
temperaturausgleich ich bin gespannt
normalerweise funktioniert es nicht weil
es dann klumpt da hat man so aka aka
stückchen unter drin
das bin ich immer ein bisschen eklig
anscheinend geht es noch
keine klümpchen und jetzt noch gibt die
sahne unterheben kommt dem masse direkt
auf den novak tortenboden schön glatt
streichen und dann nehmt ihr eure
eingekochten wärme und wenn sie jetzt zu
fest geworden sind führte einfach noch
ein bisschen zitronensaft wasser oder
zum beispiel in der kreisklasse
damit sei einfach schön glatt sind und
jetzt hier darauf verteilen
erst mal ein bisschen ein bisschen hebe
ich noch auf nehmen jetzt die palette
und verstreicht es jetzt so dass es sich
mit der oberen schicht einfach so ein
bisschen verbindet so einen leichten
marmor effekt dann kommen noch mal die
restlichen bern obendrauf
alex artig und die können wir dann zum
beispiel mit einer gabel mit einer gabel
marmorieren so gabriel
und dann kommt die torte einfach für
etwa drei stunden in den kühlschrank
oder für eine stunde in den
gefrierschrank
das geht auch jetzt die torte durch
gekühlt und ich kann es ja auch
herauslösen
sie ist auch schön fest geworden und hat
also alles geklappt
[Musik]
schon bevor ist der regen runter kommt
erstmal auf eine tortenplatte setzen und
dann das backpapier darunter wegziehen
ich löste es jetzt erstmal dann am
besten mit der palette so ein bisschen
am rand entlang streichen damit die
creme auch wieder schön glatt und so
können wir servieren
[Musik]
und jetzt müssen wir gleich den der mark
dazu rufen ok x days und knopf da können
wir drauf drücken und sagen sehr mag
sehr mag bitte in die kirche kommen und
los sehr mag ich muss rein sprechen hier
erinnern
dann sprechen sie ins licht
hier mag in die küche bieten verschickt
ich darf an uns gehört er kommt immer
dann kommt da schon ja
er hat ihn gebacken kriegt auch ein
stück das auch schön du bist ein joghurt
der joghurt ja cool divison joghurt ist
damit die arena nur zu einer mischung
demo hat sagt er dass immer weniger was
schmeckt süß schmeckt wie joghurt der
joghurt dann ist man lobt geld wie
schmeckt
hast du gut gebacken eigentlich um
endlich gepackt denn der backofen blieb
kalt heute wie schmeckt dir nicht
aufrecht kommen schlechten einmal ab
überall hat selbst torten krieg ist gut
so welt.de komme ich ganz schnell aus
dem kühlschrank und sowas hört man denkt
dass diese knusprig da helfe ich dir
verboten passt auch gut suchen ja oben
so christiane boden perfekt ist ist zu
viel creme zu wenigen in europa auf mich
zu wenig frucht dann ob sie schon mal
gedacht so ein bisschen mehr kriegen
wäre schön gewesen aber ich glaube dann
wird es zu viel dann schlägt ein dünnes
polster es gut
so herrsche also wenn ihr die torte nach
machen möchtet dann schaut auch cds -
block der ev da steht noch mal alles
ganz genau und ihr könnt natürlich die
früchte ersetzen wie ihr möchtet ihr
könnt auch nur etwa nehmen nur
heidelbeeren brombeeren himbeeren so wie
er oder was eben am liebsten habt ich
glaube da schmeckt die torte auch gut
genug auch noch probieren lassen
das also euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
postet auf jeden fall ein foto von ihrer
tochter wenn diese nach macht und wir
sehen uns wieder das nächste mal
[Musik]